catherine deneuve bonsoir
le film est particulièrement bien
accueillis j'ai le sentiment peut-être
je me trompe et je crois pas vous avez
un plaisir particulier à apporter à
parler du film
oui c'est vrai que c'est vrai que c'est
tourné avec andré téchiné retrouver
gérard depardieu partir comme ça à deux
mois à tanger pour tout d'une histoire
ou dans laquelle on s'investit
complètement pendant deux mois c'est
malheureusement on n'a pas tous les
jours l'occasion de partir comme ça de
quitter le banc donner tous et de
s'investir dans un film pendant deux
mois à l'étranger c'est une situation
idéale surtout pour une histoire d'amour
comme la sortie d'un film c'est un peu
comme un premier rendez vous on y va
avec le coeur qui bat beaucoup
d'affluence s'ils ont toujours beaucoup
d'appréhension oui parce que on a beau
penser que que le film est intéressant
on a beaucoup aimé les personnages on a
beau penser qu' il ya toujours ces
mystères qui existe à la journée j'ai
l'impression que vous avez besoin d'un
sécurité en fait de cette appréhension
d'insécurité besoin de surprendre de 500
guérir je dis jamais là où on vous
attend tout à fait la sécurité je crois
que en tous les cas si c'est trop de
sécurité je pense n'est pas un n'est pas
une très bonne chose pour pour les
acteurs mais pour les réalisateurs non
plus je pense qu'ils font des scènes un
peu d'incertitude beaucoup de doutes
pour être plus vigilant le danger c'est
la routine quand on a fait beaucoup de
films comme moi c'est ce serait le
danger alors peut-être en quelques mois
en quoi le personnage de ces sites peut
vous toucher ou peu de vous ressemblez
dans sa dans sa violence dans sa
brusquerie dont là l'idée que dans la
vie rien n'est jamais définitif que même
si elles refusent très violemment cet
homme qui revient faire qui réapparaît
dans sa vie comme ça c'est trop violent
pour que ce soit normal et l'idée que
oui curial et sûr dans ce domaine et
qu'en effet on peut on peut retrouver
quelqu'un qu'on a aimé c'est une chose
que j'envisage très bien nous sommes
très plausible vous croyez au deuxième
souffle à la deuxième chance au même
souffle plus que deuxième fois que je
crois que le domaine des sentiments je
crois que l'idée de l'amour c'est qu'on
ne sait jamais ce qui vous attends je
trouve que c'est la chose devant
laquelle nous sommes tous les plus égaux
c'est que l'amour est quelque chose qui
ne se voit la seule chose qu'on peut
essayer de comprimés qu'on peut essayer
de masquer
mais c'est une chose à laquelle tout le
monde a droit et voilà ça fait vraiment
quelque chose en parler bien je trouve
ça très intéressant à andré andré
téchiné a dit cette phrase que j'ai
retenu que sont assez belles vous êtes
avec gérard depardieu dit il des acteurs
en vacances de leur propre personnage
capable de retrouver la grâce des
débutants parce que c'est au fond le
plus beau compliment qu'on peut vous
jouer sachant que c'est un vrai
compliment parce que gérard et moi on a
d'abord fait beaucoup de films ensemble
et c'est vrai que là l'idée qu'on allait
retrouver notre passé de cinéma andré
téchiné voulait s'en servir et c'est
vrai qu'il ya cette logique qui fait que
en général il faut qu'en mer au moins un
quart d'heure pour arriver oublier un
acteur dans un film il ne pas avoir tous
les autres personnages de ses films
d'avant qui viennent ce riz cru c'est
donc ils font ça mais là c'est vrai que
notre passé à l'un et à l'autre sert
sert les personnages du film je pense
que c'est oui je pense que c'est positif
ça alors je veux aussi vous disiez que
j'étais un bon petit soldat sur un
tournage
on n'y aura pas de bagarre oui une pause
comme un soldat oui non mais si oui
c'est cher à côté ce qui compte c'est
cesser le fils oui c'est vrai que je
suis tout à fait capable de faire passer
l'intérêt du film avant mes propres oui
et c'est peut-être pour ça que vous
auriez pas en vue vous même de passer
derrière la caméra de tourner votre
propre film
non c'est pas pour ça c'est parce que je
ne me sens pas capable si vous voulez
moi j'ai eu la chance de tourner avec
des très grands cinéastes qui sont
vraiment des auteurs des réalisateurs je
vois c'est une très grande idée du
cinéma est pour moi simplement veut dire
que techniquement je serai cap avec des
bons techniciens de mettre un simon sène
qui je ne porte pas une histoire je
cours pas un sujet je me fais encore oui
je crois aujourd'hui une trop grande
idée du cinéma pour avoir l'impression
de pouvoir passer de l'autre côté
peut-être une dernière question vous
avez écrit des carnets tournage oui j'ai
tenu pendant pendant pendant que je
tournais son égard des calories est un
bien grand absent c'est en fait en effet
en brique et chimie oui alors avec moi
j'ai besoin d j'ai fait plusieurs films
avec lui mais c'est vrai que beaucoup de
films importants que j'ai tourné ya pas
de carnet parce que j'ai souvent
tournées à l'étranger c'est plutôt à
l'étranger que ses carnets ont été
écrits et c'est vrai que c'était des
compagnons de solitude et c'est vrai que
il ya des choses très étonnant donc
j'imagine une certaine frustration parce
qu'en effet il n'y a pas but no n ya pas
truffaut il n'y a pas il n'y a pas de
mise
parce que vous êtes en famille qui avait
rien à rien à dire quand on se sent plus
serein
vraiment surtout des tournages à
l'étranger ou des moments disons de
solitude c'est ce que j'écrivais le soir
ou pendant le week-end c'était assez
particulier au moins d'un seul mot
qu'est ce que vous avez envie de
compiègne du film que dans la vie de
travail et je crois c'est une belle
morale merci à catherine deneuve d'avoir
répondu en direct à nos questions c'est
la fin